I'm Emily Batty, a Canadian Olympic mountain bike racer.
One of my goals since I was a little girl was to own a Porsche.
For as long as I can remember, my dreams have been to be a world champion.
Having a racing career has given me the platform...
...to hopefully inspire the next generation.
That really, really speaks to me.
When I was little and one of the elite women...
...came and spoke to me individually...
...and that has resonated with me my whole career...
...and I know the importance that it has on young girls...
...looking up for role models.
To be part of the Porsche family and community is so exciting for me.
You know, their attention to detail and their passion behind performance is...
...what motivates me in my career, and just the merge of the two...
...is just such a natural fit for me.
Equipment has a crucial part in your role for success.
Your equipment is an extension of you.
So, engineering truly is everything.
A lot like my bike when I'm driving my Porsche, I look for...
...those similar handling feelings and the corner capability...
...and the braking and the throttle; it's such a divine experience.